the jets with the second overall pick in
the draft
they may or may not take a quarterback
there was a report today and it makes a
lot of sense they're not going to do
anything with sam darnold according to
in rap reporter nfl media until they
evaluate all of the options available to
them in the draft they're going to have
the control of the board after trevor
lawrence you take trevor lawrence off
the board they're running the show they
can decide whatever they want to do zach
wilson if that's the guy you want fine
trade down a little bit and take
somebody else you can do that too but
they need to evaluate all of these
quarterbacks to the point where they
understand who they are and what they
can do
to the same level where they understand
what sam darnold is and what he can do
and it's just it's just sensible to do
that but what it tells me is if they
decide to go with a quarterback at the
top of round one darnold will be gone
they're not going to try to work out
some year or and it would be one year
not two where you keep darnold at the
fourth year of his
rookie contract is the third overall
pick in 2018 plus the second overall
picks rookie contract in 2021 the the
the town isn't big enough for both guys
and if they they pick a quarterback it
looks like darnold will be gone shireen
yeah and mike let's not preclude a trade
either there we you know if if the tax
absolutely pulled the trigger on desean
watson i would expect him to be on that
too
i don't expect sam darnold to be a part
of this team next season i really don't
i think they'll go a different direction
at quarterback but i do think it's smart
and i think it's common sense that you
look at him you look at every play he
had on the field you look at the people
around him how much was him how much was
the people around him not having all
that much talent around him and what do
you have in the draft do you like any of
those guys better so there's a lot to
evaluate here for the jets moving
forward mike before they decide who's
going to be their quarterback in 2021
and this is the easy way to look at it
franchise quarterbacks declare
themselves fairly early regardless of
who's around them regardless who the
coach is regardless of who the players
are a franchise quarterback is know it
when you see it fairly quickly in his
time in the nfl they have a way of
popping sam darnold has not popped when
the most memorable quote from sam
darnold is he was seeing ghosts during a
monday night game against the patriots
in 2019 that is not know it when you see
it franchise quarterback and the jets
want that kind of clear and obvious
franchise quarterback and i think we've
seen enough from sam darnold to know
that's not what he's going to be could
it be a very good start in the nfl yes
could he be a guy who takes a team to a
super bowl absolutely could he win a
super bowl yes depending upon what's
around him but this is not a patrick
mahomes lamar jackson josh allen level
all three guys taken the same year that
darnold was taken by the way this is not
the kind of guy that is an obvious
franchise quarterback and through three
years
with sam darnold
we should have seen it by now if it was
ever going to be there and i think it's
safe to say it's it's just not going to
be there watch he'll be the mvp this
year for some other team
[Laughter]
well and it's just what you said might
we talk about the sizzle
no jets fan is going to be excited about
having sam darnold returned as their
quarterback nobody's gonna be excited by
that so you if you get another
quarterback in there whether it's via
trade or the draft i think jets fans do
get excited they they see the future
differently maybe they do than they do
with sam darnold returning as their
quarterback mike
yeah i i i think that that he won't be
there i agree with you the question is
will it be a rookie or will they get in
on one of these other trades whether
it's deshaun watson
or russell wilson when you consider that
they hold the second overall pick
and another first round pick the
seahawks first round pick and next year
they have two first round picks on top
of it
they have the ammunition to be the team
that can get the attention of either the
seahawks or the texans if those teams
decide to make a move with the
quarterbacks that they have all right
let's do the same thing that we did for
the jaguars one guy in one guy out
shireen give me somebody who's out there
that you think could end up being a
member of the new york jets with joe
douglas's gm and robert salah as head
coach
well mike richard sherman makes a ton of
sense right because of his leadership
standpoint and his relationship with
robert salah he can preach what salah
wants him to preach
with that team and bring some leadership
qualities to a defense that was terrible
last year 24th in defense 25th against a
pass i know there's better cornerbacks
probably out there on the free agent
market but he just makes a ton of sense
with his experience in the system in the
solace system his experience with salah
uh and and the fact that you know he he
can still play mike and and i just think
from a leadership quality he just makes
a ton of sense uh for the jets at this
point assuming they have a good
relationship we are assuming they have a
good relationship maybe they don't we
don't know about it but assuming they
have a good relationship it just makes
too much sense
yeah i'm not gonna go full freezing cold
takes here and say there's no way the
jets will sign richard sherman but i
will say this it is a situation to
monitor very carefully as it relates to
the question of whether the jets even
get in on the action because i've heard
time and again the 49ers had enough of
richard sherman he's not good enough at
this point in his career to be as big of
a personality on the team as he is and
that
robert saleh is not likely to want
richard sherman at this stage of his
career in his locker room influencing
younger players
in large part because sherman isn't good
enough to justify putting up with the
baggage that comes from having an
outspoken guy who's going to naturally
lead
and
this may not be the guy that robert
salah wants his young players to follow
so
again i'm not saying it won't happen i'm
saying it's going to be a fascinating
litmus test as to whether or not there
is interest and
if robert sala and the jets aren't at
the front of the line
for richard sherman
i think any other team no doubt should
be saying
maybe there's a reason robert saul is
not at the front of the line for richard
sherman i i've got a couple of different
ones but pass rush i think is so
important for this team carrie hyder's
been great for the 49ers during the the
injury replacement rush of this past
year should be gotten fairly
inexpensively for the jets i think
carrie hyder makes sense if they want to
go a little more expensive make a
running on a congo but one thing we saw
when that 49ers defense is working well
what does it have it has pass rushers
off the edge and i think that's what joe
douglas and robert sala need to target
give me somebody who's going to be out
well i think the obvious candidate and
i'll be really surprised if he's back on
this roster is henry anderson he was a
terrible signing he's got a ton he's got
a bad contract he's a way overpaid
9.5 million if they keep him mike if
they move on from him they can save 8.2
million which makes a ton of sense i
mean he just hasn't been good for them a
bad signing now he's overpaid you got to
get rid of this guy and move on and
upgrade your pass rush elsewhere
you know another guy that that i think
needs to be on the radar screen although
they don't have a lot of receivers when
you've got jameson crowder with a 10.375
million dollar cap figure
for 20 20 there's already been some
reports that he may get whacked it just
it won't surprise me but you got to have
other plans at receiver and you know are
you going to turn around and spend that
money on juju smith schuster are you
going to go after chris godwin i mean
they need guys at the receiver position
especially if they're going to try to
upgrade at quarterback one of the
reasons sam darnold maybe hasn't been as
good as he needs to be is he hasn't had
a great array of weapons around him but
uh i i would not be surprised if the
10.375 million earmarked for
a crowder ends up going to some other
receiver that they make a run at serene
and free agency
yeah i had chris godwin mike and i just
think it's going to be hard for the
buccaneers to franchise either one of
those guys shaq barrett or chris godwin
and we know they're going to lose some
players despite what they've said it
sounds great that they're going to take
that hometown discount and come back and
try to win a second consecutive super
bowl we know the realities of this it's
all about money mike
those guys are going to get more money
elsewhere so chris godwin is one i think
probably won't be franchise tagged and
probably will go elsewhere and i the
jets should be in on him
you know shaq barrett is a guy that they
much more desperately need to keep in
tampa bay because of what he brings to
the past rush and i don't want to
minimize the skills of chris goblin but
the reality is you bump antonio brown up
on the depth chart you've got scottie
miller and tyler johnson and the
buccaneers will be in position as other
teams shed
veteran free agents if receivers are cut
when receivers are cut that's when the
tom brady factor kicks in and that's
when you can get somebody potentially to
come take
very little to be on the depth chart and
to be catching passes from tom brady
whoever it may be and there will be
plenty of recognizable names that are
available on the open market and chris
goblin is going to be in a position
where he attracts so much money i don't
expect him to say no why should he say
no but the buccaneers aren't going to
match whatever's out there and you only
got one franchise tag to use and if
you're going to use it you use it on
shaq barrett now what they could try to
do is a long-term deal with shaq barrett
before the two week window for applying
the franchise tag expires two weeks from
tomorrow and then put it on chris goblin
but there's only so many cap dollars
especially this year it's not going to
be easy to do so
there will be
young receivers on the front end of
their prime available for the jets if
they're ready to pay and that's the
question how much money are they going
to budget shireen for a guy like a chris
godwin or a juju smith schuster you
think about the offense that mike
lafleur comes from in san francisco and
how how hard-nosed the receivers are and
how they have him involved in the
running game like adibo samuel i can see
juju smith schuster in that role
yeah oh absolutely mike and i also think
they need more obviously from denzel
mims i mean they spent the second round
pick on him last year they've got to see
more injuries and other things he had
two hamstring injuries that really set
him back didn't play a ton of games but
he did have a five-game stretch there
mike when he had six catches of 20-plus
yards he's shown big catch ability i
think you'll see more out of this guy
next year too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports